What's up guys, thanks for joining us today on the king of random
We are back at the dome as you can see and we've brought our flamethrower
Again today that we're not going to be shooting fire
We're going to try and experiment to see what other types of things we can squirt out of our high pressured flamethrower
I guess at that point. It's not a flamethrower. It's a whatever thrower
We're gonna mix up a giant bucket full of this
Gelatinous slime put it into the tank of our flamethrower and see if we can shoot green slime up to 50 feet
This powder is made by jelly bath, and it's what we're gonna be using today to make our green slime
I'm not exactly sure how much of this stuff you need to get it to the right consistency
So I'm going to add a couple of packets see how it does and if I need to add more
I'll add a little bit more I
Think it's scented kind of smells good
What I poured in is something that absorbs the water and expands a little bit
Which is what turns it into a gelatinous blobby stuff so now
I just need to let it sit for a bit and let it absorb some of the water
You can already see getting some nice slimy ooze coming out of this. There's a slightly different shade of green but
It's all cream should work. All right. It's been soaking for a little while
I'm not a hundred percent clear on how long you're supposed to let it wait, but I'm just gonna start mixing it up
Maybe that'll help things along a little bit
Gross
Look at that
Slimy boozy mess
Alright, well this stuff has sort of been working. We've got a little bit of thickness
It's kind of slimy, but it's not what I was expecting
I did a test with this on a smaller scale not with the flame thrower
But just mixing some of it up last night, and I had a much more gelatinous four result
I was using this purple stuff then and I'm wondering if the green is actually a different product
So I'm gonna actually just add the purple to this as well
I don't know. What color we're gonna get but I think it will help it thicken up quite a bit more
Let's try this out
Wow you can see that reacting immediately as the little tiny beads of powder start absorbing water is just
Expanding dizzy. This is like a lesson in tectonic plates right here
This is why we get earthquakes as plates expand. They hit each other they dive into each other
You can see mountain ranges are forming here. That's actually kind of cool like everything is got a pad tectonics work
Although there aren't any that I see where one is going under the others women bug
So before it was slimy and now it's a lot more of a gelatin
I'm just gonna mix it all together
Still mostly green just a little bit more subdued green color
Let's let that sit for about 10 minutes
Let the purple stuff absorb as much water as it can and really stiffen up you come back and see what we've got
All right, we've had this sitting for like 10 minutes now
And I actually went ahead and just added even more because it wasn't going fast enough
Which I guess means it could eventually set so much that we can't really pour it or anything but right now
I'm at least pretty happy with this
We've got some good slimy ooze here
And I think this is gonna look great shooting out of our claim code or slime throat as it is now
Now it's like swamps line instead of Ninja Turtle slime
I'm just gonna change some gloves real quick
So I'm able to hold on to stuff while I'm pouring it and we'll fill up our tank
All right, let's open up our tank
We have here the largest funnel I could find
It just barely fits in
Plastic is actually doing a pretty good job of supporting that so now
I'm gonna try and pour from our giant bucket into this to help me out my friend Keith is here from Kay face TV up
Guys lift this up and see if we can pour it in without coating absolutely everything in slime
Yes victory all right so that didn't work out perfectly
And by that I mean it didn't really work out
Just puddle of who's here there. We go. I his slimy green ooze
All right this time holding the funnel in place oh
There's slime running all down this flamethrower container. It's a doozy. Gooey slime right there oh?
Man
I'll have to
Wipe that down a little bit or put it on. We'll grab some towels try and clean that off. Oh
Gross
All right our tank is full like almost to the top with slime now
Let's close it off and add some pressure
We've got our co2 tank here. I'm sure we probably could use compressed air for this one where we've already got some co2 tanks
We're just gonna use them
Alright, let's open this
I'm gonna open and then close this valve again because that gave us better results with the flamethrower
I'm guessing it well with this line as well
All right, there's the pressure
And I'll close this close this one
Now let's strap it on and see how it squirts all I stepped in it gross oh
I think that jelly is heavier than gasoline
Thank you
All right now the propane tank is still attached, but obviously this isn't flammable. I'm not gonna be using that this time
I'm just gonna be spraying it out and see what happens when you push
gelatin through a nozzle with 800 psi
Really great here. We go first test of our 800 psi slime thrower
3 2 1
Disgusting that's just jelly in the air
Whoo oh that's so gross looking through the air
I'm looking forward to this he's disgusting slimy ooze here we go
It's just a constant stream of slime coming out of it, and it is getting smaller and smaller as the pressure diminishes
now it looks like the world's fastest snail spent the day here just running around in circles still go and
still go and
I ran out of slime
So that looks pretty good right at first. I was shooting about 40 feet just slime in this nice
Constrained beam and then it's splatters everywhere on the ground. It's kind of gross, and yeah, it really looks like a slime monster
Just died here or something. It's everywhere, so let's do it again
Boy a time travel
To the future chug
And is like that this is getting lighter bubbling swampies
I'm gonna try shooting directly onto the dome and I'm gonna try and write out the word random
We'll see how well that works out all right?
Here goes nothing
Probably should have written it a little smaller, but hey random in slime like I thought it's kind of hard to read but
Slide
It is super easy and gross
Oh
That's gooey. Gooey. Gross. This really keeps going low-pressure for a while just making puddles of ooze everywhere
Well, I think we've got enough slime and enough co2 for one more round
But uh we have to take this to the next level. I think I'm gonna have to get slimed all right. Let's fill er up
Now we've suited Keith up he's got the slime thrower I'm gonna be against the wall
And I'm going to get slimed keith is discovering how heavy this time thrower is when it's full he's so heavy
Whenever you're ready
Endless love
It doesn't wipe off
Its just live my head's covered it so I can't really
Get rid of it
Well, I think I need a towel in the shower and then probably like six more showers after that
I literally like can barely open this. I just because there's lime holding it closed I
Literally have pockets full of slime that
Is a flamethrower filled with slime and shot out at about 800 psi
Sometimes it felt like it was about 800 psi. Well. It's getting hit that was little high pressure, but that
Was really fun kind of takes you back to the glory days of when?
Nickelodeon would dump slime all over people this has been a lot of fun
There's definitely some more things we want to try shooting out of our flamethrower because that's pretty entertaining
You've got any really good ideas of stuff you want to see us try and shoot out of our flamethrower
Let us know down in the comments. Thanks for joining us to this project and we'll see you the next one talky then
Guys in the shot we don't know who he is just wandering on set actually have this step two which is designed to dissolve
What you mixed up before?
I'm pretty sure it's just table salt. Oh my gosh
My glasses won't even stay up because they're just like slippery and my hair is slippery
Well, that's that's what I'm gonna use instead of shampoo from now on
Hey guys
I hope you loved this video as much as we loved making it for you because if you didn't and I guess we books just
Wasted our time, but we are literally working on the next one right now
So we'll see you as soon as we get it finished back to you then